good day and welcome everyone i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
please allow me to welcome you to this
edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series
this lecture is supported by uva's
integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it's my privilege and honor today to
welcome our speaker dr satrajit ghosh
from the mcgovern institute for brain
research at massachusetts institute of
technology
dr ghosh received his bachelor of
science degree with honors in computer
science from the national university of
singapore
he then earned a phd in cognitive and
neural systems from boston university
dr ghosh is principal research scientist
at the mcgovern institute for brain
research
and an assistant professor of
otolaryngology at harvard university
school of medicine
he directs the sensible intelligence
group whose research portfolio comprises
projects on spoken communication
brain imaging and informatics to address
the gaps in scientific knowledge in
three different areas
the neural basis and translational
applications of human spoken
communication
machine learning approaches to precision
psychiatry and medicine
and preserving information for
reproducible research
he is also the director of data models
and integration
um as part of the repronym project an
nih p41 center for reproducible
neuroimaging computation
finally amongst his many accomplishments
dr gauche is the co-pi of the dandy
project
a u.s brain initiative data archiving
effort for cellular neurophysiology
as well as one of the prime movers of
the nype open software development
effort
dr gush's lecture today is entitled the
shifting dunes of data in computation
and as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via
youtube
if you are watching by youtube today
thank you so much for joining us
and also if you are one of our specially
selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants you are encouraged to
submit your questions for dr gauche
by the chat feature in your zoom session
i will synthesize these questions and
i'll ask them on your behalf towards the
end of the lecture
and with that welcome satra thank you so
much for joining us we're really looking
forward to your lecture
hey thank you jack it's a pleasure to be
here and before i move forward
i will want to acknowledge the efforts
of so many collaborators and members of
the group
over the many years and i'm going to
kind of span a couple of decades of
information today so i want to thank
all the people who have contributed and
influenced many of the things
uh i have done and we continue to do
today we're also very grateful for
support from the national institute of
health
support that we've received from the
incf over the years
and also internal support from the
mcgovern institute neurotechnology fund
as jack mentioned uh our group kind of
focuses on
three broad areas or branches of study
we want to understand the
neurophysiology of human communication
we want to do applied machine learning
especially in the context of precision
medicine and psychiatry
and we want to preserve knowledge
through reproducible research and other
neuroinformatics approaches
but what i'm going to focus on broadly
today is in this brain imaging and
analytics section
of our work and i wanted to start by
simply showing
what we can do with a single subject
today this is not super complicated but
we can look at things
at an individual level on a brain and
what you're looking at on the left
is an inflated brain it's like taking
the brain and blowing it up a little bit
like a balloon
uh so that you can peer into the cracks
and crevices
uh or the gyra and salsa of the brain
and on the right is the stimulus
that the subject was seeing and we're
going to look at a real-time
functional activation as the person is
looking at those
timily i should note that this video has
been edited
to compress it into a very short time
span
but it does follow the patterns that you
would expect to see
i wish i would play music for you at
this point and at this point in time the
person is reading this aloud
in the scanner and as you may have
noticed there's there were some
very specific patterns of activity as
they were watching these different
components of the tasks
but we did not quite start in the space
where we could do this
easily we had questions around speech
production
and scientific questions often need
specific data and tools
so when we started we were looking to
build a model or neural computational
model of speech production
and we were looking at how neuroimaging
could inform us
to build such a model and one of the
papers we were looking at at that point
in time
was something about the computational
side of neuroimaging
this is from katrin almonds who was
looking at a standard
process at that time which was to take
brains
and normalize or register them to each
other
and when people did that what katrina
did was looked at
broadband areas 17 and 18 parts of
visual cortex
and said when you align people using
this normalization method
as you increase the number of
overlapping brains
the number of voxels or pieces of the
brain that actually overlap across
people
starts diminishing rather rapidly now
this was important for us
in the context of us trying to study the
speech
motor control system and so we took that
kind of effort
onto the temporal lobe and asked the
same kinds of questions and demonstrated
the same kinds of things
and this led us to the notion that we
couldn't be using the standard tools in
use at that time
to try and understand how the speech
motor control system work
so painstakingly every single individual
was anatomically parcelated into regions
of
interest that then we could relate from
one individual to another
and study to understand the functional
architecture
of speech motor control in the brain
what so on one hand
we were doing the science of trying to
understand speech motor control
on the other hand this required us
developing probably our first set of
tools
we created a matlab based interactive
editor
that jason torvill and for those of you
who do brain imaging
the t interval is the same as the dkt in
the dkt atlas
that's distributed through free surfer
and alfonso nieto castanon
who today you might know as the lead
developer of the
khan library at that time we created
this matlab interface for json to
quickly parselate and quickly meant
several hours of work
on the right you kind of see an
operational flowchart and
this workflow seems rather
straightforward and simple you get
scanner data
you analyze it you take the
pre-processed data and you
bifurcate that into a couple of
different analysis
and this entire thing created what we
would call perhaps the first
batch processing system at that time
for spm spm's batch editor had not yet
been
built but it also was a
place and time when we were developing
things in matlab
writing code in c and c plus interacting
with vtk and free surfer and putting
computational geometry into our tools
and it gave us a foray into creating a
set of tools that helps one answer
specific questions
when standard tools are not possible it
was also around that time
that you could get
data but get data by having it mailed to
you
and this is an example of us requesting
data
from the fmri data center and it was
mailed to us
in cds that we could then load and
take a look at the world started
changing
about four or five years later and one
of the things that started happening
was an explosion of the set of tools
packages and algorithms that were
available
for neuroimaging we
saw an exponential growth in these
packages
but they were also containing
differences in
algorithms they made differences in
assumptions
they ran on different platforms they had
different interfaces
they often relied on different data
formats since in
for some of these tools so as the space
was growing
the world of neuroimaging was starting
to ask the question
could i use different packages for
different kinds of things
and here's an example on the right of a
section
in a paper around fmri data
pre-processing
and you're already starting to see that
people are using a couple of different
packages
to build together workflows and
pipelines
to process such data it was also around
this time that data started getting much
more multimodal
we were acquiring anatomical images
we're acquiring functional images
we were looking at diffusion images for
looking at
water diffusion as a proxy for
connectivity in the brain
around the same time the ecosystem
around python
was growing for those of you who might
consider python a de facto thing today
around that time when we started
building the nypi project
we had to put up this slide on
introduction to computer science and
programming at mit being taught in
python
to convince many people that python is a
real language that people should be
using
to do scientific work and there was an
incredible community of people
uh led by many people around the world
developing these scientific tools in
python
and this is what led us to one of the
first tools
we created that was distributed
widely called nypipe and the idea behind
ip was simple you had all these
different packages
what we wanted to do was to collate
those packages
under a single uniform python api so
that the user or the developer of the
workflow
software did not have to learn how to
call
spm through matlab or how to call a
command line interface from
fsl or free surfer it all came as a
uniform
standardized api that they could use
this did not mean that you
had the luxury of not knowing what those
tools do but it just
helped kind of putting these tools
together to construct
workflows that allowed you to mix and
match things especially as you're
starting to get into multi-modal
data from anatomy from functional data
and the fusion data
you could also use this engine to
distribute your computation
initially it was to workstations in the
lab at that time
uh through ssh and later on it became
one of those things that you could run
on hpc clusters
and chris gargolefsky was one of the
lead architects of making this
happen uh he was in boston for six
months
we released one of the major versions
first versions of
nypi over a one-week sprint
that then i think changed the landscape
of some of the pipeline based computing
that we see today nightpipe is in use
an almost 88 countries today
and it has spurred the development of
several packages that rely on it
and an entire new ecosystem
of tools and workflows that were
spearheaded
very much by chris and oscar and the
other chris uh who's now helping
maintain
many of these different pieces so this
ecosystem is what we see today
but it started about 10 years back and
it is at that point in time
10 years back that we were looking at
various ways
of accessing data software
openly also creating collaborations that
were open
some of the online systems like github
had just come online
and we were able to leverage some of
these things to accelerate
the software or the analytic
collaborations that were happening
and it was also spearheaded by two other
things
around that time the international
neuroinformatics coordinating facility
or incf
created the neuroimaging data sharing
task force
uh and the neuro bureau started
collaborating
on creating an open space for scientists
and researchers
to work together collaboratively through
brain hacks and other events
what was important at that time and this
was again looking at about ten years
nine to ten years back that we were
already starting to think
about how to capture information in a
way
that is reusable a few weeks back
i know marianne martone gave a talk in
this
seminar series on fairness or fair
data and available digital objects
some of that started at this point in
time
we were looking at how do we represent
metadata
how do we develop methods to ensure
interoperability across
different tools and packages and how do
we distribute this in a way that it's
reusable
by others and this
started a project called the newer
imaging data model project
which involves many people over the
years
in trying to structure information
that's accessible
at various levels we built this
specifically relying on something called
the provenance model
something that would allow us to
increase our trust in our data and
results by knowing where they came from
the core technologies behind this were
one of the things that was written in
this cern document
almost 21 years back at that time by tim
berners-lee
in showing how one could relate
different pieces of information
on the web and this is the model that we
are using
even today and it is increasingly
becoming clear
that a lot of information that's coming
online
needs to be connected and related to
each other provenance needs to be
tracked so neural imaging
the neuroimaging data model was one of
the starting pieces of this
a key piece of this was also about
harmonization of information
at that point in time we were starting
to get access to
thousands of brain mri images
through initiatives that were
spearheaded by mike milham
at the child mind institute and cameron
craddock we got access to a lot of data
this was made available through an
interactive
interface where one could search
for data sets through different aspects
of phenotypic
information and it could be things like
diagnosis
this involved individuals with adhd or
autism
or control subjects or they could be
looking at various other aspects of
phenotypes
and this created what we at that time
called open neuroimaging laboratory
and perhaps the earliest use of the word
open neuro
although open euro today is a very
different thing it's a fantastic
resource
of data created by chris and russ and
others
in distributing fmri data sets
the intent of creating a distribution
like meta search to be able to search
through it was not just
accessing data or seeing what's out
there publicly
it was also about creating a community
of people who would come together to
edit
brain images uh collaboratively using a
browser-based platform
and this was one of the first forays
into browser-based technologies for
collaborative work
and this is something that's continued
on today by roberto and
katia and one could go in there
collaboratively edit a brain and then
render
a brain which in this particular case is
that of a black rhinoceros but
a lot of it was intended as going across
brains not just across species but a lot
of human brains from different
projects
so this led to a lot of data coming
online
and but the data came online in
different ways
and one of the things that happened with
an idm
was as a graph and a semantic web model
it was partly seen as fairly complex
with no tools and technologies
to actually create the metadata or the
needs
that would be or the descriptors that
would be
required to express data in searchable
form
on the other hand you had completely
unstructured pdfs which people are still
used to today
you read through it you understand what
was distributed and then you go
find it the brain imaging data structure
which was formulated around this time in
2015
chose this middle ground of coming to a
community consensus about a file layout
and organization with consensus metadata
it did not try to
make it rich with the linked data
semantics that knightm
does but it provided something that was
acceptable to a large community
and a set of technologies that the
community could understand and build
towards
and i think it's a fantastic example of
how
you want to think about tools in the
context of your audience
as opposed to perhaps the complete
notion of
technology developers that might be
needed to build an infrastructure around
it
so i'll take the human connectome
project as an example while here i'm
saying it was primarily unstructured
data that you had to find and
do things with it ushered in a set of
data
that was fantastic today that project
has grown and will be releasing
even more data over the next year but
when
it first started the primary data set
that was available was the young adult
human connectome project
and in that data set which
at that point we were playing with had
about 500 subjects
so that was already an a few orders of
magnitude
uh larger than most data sets in
people's labs
and this raised various kinds of
challenges for us
one of the things we were interested in
was to try and understand
whether resting state functional data
could be
used to do better alignment of
individuals to each other
remember very early on i said one of the
things people normally did
was to take volumetric images
and align one brain to another or to a
template
we found that to be difficult at least
in those early days
and used region-based analysis
to do things but anatomical regions
while they govern some aspects of
functionality
are not an identical map for all aspects
of functionality
at the macro scale level so resting
state data
which literally involves somebody lying
in a scanner
and you're monitoring their brain
activity as it spontaneously fluctuates
over time
provides some amount of structure
to the patterns that emerge and this
gives rise to specific types of networks
and our question was could we use this
to look at
how two people are similar to each other
and we relied on some mathematical
techniques
which creates this matrix of
correspondences
now the human connectome project data
allows us
to do this for every single individual
here's an example of looking at it
for three individuals they may have
different regions in the brain that
relate
similarly to each other but you can kind
of align them all together
using a procrustes or other types of
transforms into a common space
now the challenge here was that the
human connector project data
released data that were about 90 000
rows or points and if you construct this
matrix that would be a 90 000
square matrix if you stored the 90 000
square matrix on a computer
it will as a floating point number or a
matrix of floating point numbers
that will take about 64 gigabytes of ram
at that point in time not every computer
had 64 gigabytes of ram
and if you couple this now with 500
subjects worth of data
you're getting into a place where your
standard computational tools are no
longer feasible
to do some of these things so we came up
with
various ways and efficiencies to deal
with that scale of data
and that changed the mindset of what
computational infrastructure
we should be investing in even at mit
we were able to at that time think about
ways in which the future of computation
were to evolve
and preempt the construction of our
compute cluster
to leverage larger memory sizes even
though most people
weren't really solving problems that
needed that much
and this was a big boost our benefit at
that time
we were able to run this human
connectome project analysis
where we aligned people to a common
space using functional architectures
and this itself led to a series of new
ways of applying this kind of embedding
or alignment
that was spearheaded by a dear friend
and colleague
daniel margulis in looking at gradients
in the brain
both within and across species as a way
of representing
macro scale gradients of
information that go from unimodal
properties to heteromodal regions
that have now allowed people to look at
this in the context of various disorders
looking at within region gradients and
kind of thinking about
how these gradients map onto different
aspects of behavior and cognition
well many samples were kind of useful
one of the things that we were still
interested in
was going back to our understanding of
human communication
physiology so we wanted to see
how a standard diagram in a textbook
like the one you see on the left
maps on to actual human data
now it turns out that for most part
these diagrams are based on animal or
other studies
and just looking at the auditory and
visual systems
one might notice that one of the primary
differences
are the different stages of brain
regions or layers
that one goes through going from the
sensory organ so in the auditory system
the cochlea
or the visual system the retina into
perhaps the first major thoroughfare
in relation to cortex the thalamus
and the auditory system has many more
junctions whereas in the visual system
that has been compressed and a lot of
computation gets done
in the retina itself we were interested
in
trying to see if we can figure out this
pathway in vivo
in humans using these technologies that
we had access to
like mri turns out
we couldn't quite get there so instead
we stepped back
we still dealt with the human system
but using eggs vivo tissues
and we were delighted to find a data set
that was available
that involved mr imaging
of an ex vivo brain stem that goes all
the way from the brain stem
up to thalamus and these are some of the
images that come out
from this data set so on the
top row is this x vivo data set
uh on the bottom row is kind of a
standard human connectome project three
tesla scan
of the corresponding anatomy and as you
might be able to see
in this display the incredible richness
of the data that comes from the x vivo
scans so we are we were happy to see
that many people were starting to put
data out there
that they weren't intending to be used
for the purposes
we used them for but by putting the data
openly out there
we were able to reuse it for a project
that it wasn't originally necessarily
created for
and here is looking at the diffusion
orientation distribution functions and
again
a comparison on the left of the x vivo
data and on the right
of the human connectome project data
this is truly an unfair comparison on
the right
is an in-vivo scan on the left is an
x-vivo scan
but i think it's very clear the
structure and the clarity that comes
just from
looking at these orientation
distribution functions
on the on the left relative to the in
vivo scan
where we still have some ways to go to
get to the kind of clarity that the
x-vivo scan provides
and this allowed kevin who was a grad
student in the group at that time
to create a replica
of that textbook figure using the
diffusion data
that we got from the xvivo scan now for
those of you
who do diffusion mr cryptography
there's a lot of noise in the signal so
it's a little difficult to necessarily
trust everything you see or get
out of a diffusion cryptography
reconstruction so as a following step
another grad student and this is
federico di martinez who's at maastricht
university in the netherlands his grad
student faro gulban
kind of joined up with kevin to say what
can we do
to kind of extend this even further
and what they did was leverage a couple
of public data sets the xvivo dataset
that we were looking at
the big brain dataset which was released
from
mcgill and eulek and in vivo
mri data at 7t that faro can
federico had collected at maastricht in
creating a connection
between the postmodern mri the big brain
and the in vivo mri and this allowed us
to look at test retest reliability
of the localization of these functions
across
individuals and
look at different structures across test
retests within an individual
on different experimental days now
this kind of work relied on
many different new techniques to be
created including
alignment of brain data across in vivo
and xvivo scans it turned out when we
initially
did this work the registration methods
failed
and farooq and kevin had to go in and
tweak those registration methods to make
this work
you might also notice these were at very
different resolutions or scales
so most techniques were created not to
address that large discrepancies in
resolution
and were relying on resolution being
somewhat similar
to be able to align things to each other
so this also required a new set of tools
and techniques to be
generated and looked at much more
prospectively and closely
to see if these registrations worked for
people
but this was one of the things that this
produced
and in addition whatever was generated
as a result of this
was made publicly available as open data
and other compute resources
shifting gears a little bit in our group
the other thing that we started looking
at around that time
was looking at mapping genetic
information
through brain imaging data into some
level of clinical information and in
this particular case
we were looking at schizophrenia with
collaborators kehan
manglik who's now at university of
pittsburgh and joel
sanchez arahua who's now a grad student
at princeton
and we were interested in seeing if by
inserting an endophenotype so instead of
going directly from genetic data
to the clinical state if we inserted an
endophenotype like brain imaging
information
could we get an easier process
to both learn the mapping from genes
to the diagnosis state or
also map brain regions back
to genetic precursors and we tested this
by
asking the question how well could we
predict
uh the class uh the state of the
individual
using these two different methods so in
one case we just went with a standard
uh mechanism like lasso or other machine
learning techniques
that went from brain regions
to the classification stage in the other
case we used a probabilistic graphical
model
to map the genes through the
endophenotype to the disease state
and what we found was that the
probabilistic graphical model
had very similar performance to the
standard machine learning technique
the difference being we it was much much
sparser
just by the nature of the construction
of the model
we also ran an independent validation on
some external data sets
and that also showed us that this model
was doing pretty similarly on data that
it had never seen
and it provides back a marker back to
the genetic information
now what was interesting at this time
was this was one of the earliest data
sets
that was available through the genus
consortium thanks to gabriella and tracy
that had a decent number of subjects
with brain imaging data and genetic
information
we were able to constrain the genetic
information through other
much larger scale studies like the pgc
study
and were able to include different kinds
of phenotypic information to further
regress out variants in this sample
but this led us to the fact that over
the years we saw
this increasing trend in multi-modal
data sets
coming into play which requires new
analytics
new tools and new ways of looking at and
exploring
the data
so what does the next generation data
and compute infrastructure
look like one of the things that people
have access to now
is a fairly large set of data
you have various biobank projects like
the uk biobank
uh the genus project that i just
mentioned the abcd study that's
collecting longitudinal data across
about 10 000
kids the healthy brain network study
that's also plans to track 10 000 kids
and at this point in time is around 3
600
samples or so the fcp indie
project is the functional connectron
project the open neuro
and the ongoing human connectome
projects and its extensions
that are all giving rise to a scale of
data that's
very different from what people are used
to in their labs
and they these data excuse me
are spanning multiple modalities and
allows for rich exploration and
investigation
and this requires a slightly different
way of approaching things
and for this reason we just finished
running
the first iteration of the abcd repronam
course which was targeted at mixing
computational tools with exploring the
abcd data
a similar course has been run by uh
ariel rockham and tal
yarkoni for the last four years called
neuro academy
which again focuses on these
computational tools that
wouldn't be necessary to process these
scales
of diverse and heterogeneous data
and large-scale data that's coming
online today
and then over the pandemic one of the
fantastic things that happened was
neuromatch academy
which was an online school for
computational neuroscience trying to
integrate
computational neuroscience techniques as
well as giving students
an option to learn about the various
tools and resources
that one has access to and this is
some of these are being coordinated
through a platform called neurostars
which is an open platform for questions
and answers for the neuroscience
community
run by the incf and i encourage
everybody to contribute and build this
platform and looking at and responding
to questions that people create
alongside these large data sets the next
problem that kind of comes up is how do
i access this data
and on that front one of the projects
that has been coming online over the
last
five years or so is a project called
datalab
and what datalab does is it gives you
access
to a plethora of data across
the planet uh through
a git like interface now git may be
something that you're
unfamiliar with it's a version control
system
and what datalab does is it turns that
to version control data
and provide access to information that
otherwise would have been difficult
as is shown on the slide the amount of
data that
you can access through datalab is about
268 terabytes today
and this is growing at an exponential
rate
most people probably don't have space to
download that scale of data onto their
hpc systems or clusters and this is what
the unique part about datalat is
you don't need to download 268 terabytes
of data
you can download only the necessary bits
that you need
access to so in some ways it provides an
index
to an incredible assortment of data
and allows you to search for and get to
pieces of data
that you need for the question that you
have at hand
and in case you have a few petabytes of
storage you could download all the
pieces of data and store it locally
alongside this access to data
we are seeing an incredible set of tools
coming online
some of these are as old as that first
slide i showed
uh spm fsl free surfer ants and aphny
have been around for a long time and
continue to be
some of the key elements that are used
in neuroimaging analysis but there are
also a whole lot of tools coming online
in the machine learning space
including nylon which is built on top of
scikit-learn
and the various kind of standard machine
learning modules
of tensorflow pytorch and keras
on the neural imaging site itself we are
changing the ecosystem a little bit
building new general purpose tools like
pydra as a new
workflow engine test kraken a new
testing
framework uh neurodocker creating
analysis environments for docker and
singularity
and no-brainer which i will talk about
in a little bit of time
a brain dnn library and alongside these
are
highly specialized other tools like
cuticon for
com conversion mri qc various
of the night preps and knife flows that
are coming online
there are also specialized interfaces
being built
for analyzing certain types of data in
this case
analyzing data from fmri studies where
people were watching movies and this is
a project spearheaded by talia arcone
and alejandro de la vega at university
of texas austin and it's building
an online platform that allows you to
quickly select the kinds of questions
that you might want to ask of these data
sets
and create an analysis module that you
can then run
on your own cluster to get at results
from those questions
alongside such a specialized interface
there are other ways of looking at
literature and from gail varaqua's lab
one of the projects is neuro query which
allows you to ask
questions almost as if you were asking
someone a question
and it will take the entities or patents
in the question or the query
and turn them into a brain map
indicating
places or regions in the brain which
might have been responsive to those
terms or entities that were in the
question and it will link
that brain map or the creation of that
brain map to the set of publications
that were used
to create that brain map so allowing a
rich connection between a query
and literature through brain imaging
coordinates and data
so this brings me to i mentioned
no-brainer earlier as a robust and
validated
uh neural network tool suite and this is
a recent brain initiative project that
we are working on with a bunch of
collaborators
but primarily it's being run through mit
mass general hospital
and georgia state university with some
collaborations at nimh
and outside of the states
the current state of affairs is as you
have just heard an explosion of public
accessible data
there's all kinds of data coming online
there's also been an explosion of models
you have models being created for
segmentation
behavior prediction connectomics
diagnosis
and we are seeing a continued
improvement in the
computational infrastructure that
supports these models
however there are many challenges
despite all the data being available i
would say that it's still the tip of the
imaging data iceberg
there's much more clinical data that's
hidden in hospitals
also much of the open data have been
anonymized so they have gone through
transformations which make it easy to
access
data but are not realistic enough
necessarily
in relation to data that you might get
straight off of a scanner
many of the models that are being
distributed i would say still lack
a fair amount of fairness while code is
being made increasingly
available the pre-trained models are not
now this is all changing dynamically
even right now you are getting more
models that come out
but we're also seeing a rush to creating
models which don't necessarily have
robustness or validated across a very
large set of
data sets and often these are research
products that are not engineered for
production
or computational efficiency so if you
wanted to run some of these models on
the size and scale of some of the
biobank data they would take time and
effort
to do so there's also limited
consideration of data bias in many cases
and finally a lot of underspecification
is happening
as we build some of these models which
limits the utility of the models beyond
the lab
into real world spaces
so we have been building up this
framework called no-brainer
to try and kind of address some of these
challenges and here's a
couple of examples that i would like to
share with you
we've been building some base networks
for image segmentations and parcelation
we'll move on to time series
processing and surface based operations
pretty soon we were able to show that
a brain extraction network trained on 10
000 scans
could be quickly fine-tuned to provide
an
improvement for meningoma segmentation
by relying on the initial network
trained on the 10 000 scans
as opposed to training just on the
meningioma segmentation data
together with colleagues at nimh we've
developed this bayesian model on network
to not only segment brains but also to
give us a measure of uncertainty
which allows us to relate information in
a brain to the quality of the
uh image itself and this has allowed us
to kind of think about quality control
or how to
improve the quality of public data sets
right from the get-go
instead of every lab having to think and
re-evaluate quality whenever they
download the data
but this comes at a little bit of a cost
in developing this project you need to
understand
various aspects of infrastructure it is
a python library that part is
straightforward
but we are also using data lab and open
science framework to distribute models
and data
and creating containerized applications
that one
would need to understand how to use
containers to run and use
in their own centers
and when we build these resources we
have access to a set of resources
here at mit that spans different kinds
of hardware
and if somebody who had to come into the
project they would need to have some
kind of background
to be able to deal with these different
architectures infrastructures and
platforms
and be able to understand the data
modalities and infrastructure
that deals with creating such models
using brain imaging data and this is a
challenge for us right now
getting a set of people who have the
knowledge
that spans these domains is hard
and it's something that would have to
change at a fundamental level in how we
think about
training individuals computationally at
universities and other places
in neuroscience one of the things we
want to be able to do is to move beyond
a single modality and get towards
multi-scale and monthly modal
integration
and this is changing
very rapidly here at least in the u.s
and more broadly across brain
initiatives in the world
the us brain initiative has funded and
supported
a large set of data archives to capture
data
from subcellular resolution to the whole
brainscape
and one of the projects we are lucky to
be part of is
called dandy which we're treating as not
just on data archive but also hoping
that it will change the way people
interact with data
and with each other in the research
space so we call it a collaboration
space for cellular neurophysiology
projects
the basic elements of dandy like any
other application is fairly
straightforward it's a web application
that you can use
to browse various data sets but it uses
standardized descriptors which
improves the fairness of data being
distributed through dandy
we're relying on things like neurodata
without borders
bids and idm as standards that inform
the data coming into the archive
which makes it easier for people to
reuse some of these things
when they download the data onto their
own platforms
alongside the web applications we are
running a jupiter hub which is an
analytic platform
making the providing the ability for
people to do computation very close to
the data on the hub
over the last year we've grown from
about two terabytes to 13 terabytes of
data
and this is currently on a little bit of
an exponential trajectory
so i hope we would be able to kind of
think about as a community
what kind of data we should be
preserving in the long term
we don't have an answer for that right
now now to reuse this data
the data has to be richly annotated with
metadata
and we're working with various groups to
try and do so
and people who are using this archive
can use various python clients to get a
data
into and out of the archive now the
reason we were able to build this up
fairly quickly was we were relying on a
set of open source technologies
with a view that many different kinds of
people could come
and use data from this archive it could
be a hardware developer
who says i want to make it easy for
people
to submit data to dandy and i'm going to
put out data in a common format
or it could be a citizen scientist a
high school student or someone who comes
and says
i want to learn more about neuroscience
data and this data is now accessible
at their fingertips on the archive and
we have
leveraged a lot of key projects over
that have been built
by the open source community open source
and open science community
over the years that we have been able to
kind of click
together or patched together to create
this archive
and at this moment it has it has data
from four species it supports multimodal
data from intra and extracellular
uh recordings optical data mri
optical coherence demography data
microscopy data
immunostaining data and human e-cog data
it can support multi-session data and it
supports various kinds of behavioral
both manipulations and observations
through optogenetic
pre-behaving or video data sets
as i said one of the key elements of any
data distribution today
is getting information in and this still
remains a challenge for us
we want information that comes from the
scientist or the researcher to make the
data more useful
to the consumer or the end user and the
general
tagline i go with is if your lab burned
down
would you have put enough metadata onto
the archive so that you can restart your
lab with the data that's living
on the archive and this requires a
concentrated effort
not just within a lab but across a
community
to come out with better standards for
describing the data
the amount of metadata that's needed or
necessary to interpret the data
is absolutely going to be critical as we
put these archives online
the other challenge that's happening is
the amount of data that's coming online
neuropixels is a probe that's inserted
that has
about 960 channels over 10 millimeters
you can insert it at
multiple regions in the brain collect
data
and about a 13-hour recording of data
would be about a terabyte
in space now if you imagine and scale
this up across
labs doing such studies the amount of
raw data being generated
is going to soon explode and we will
have to come
to think about how to preserve data and
what to preserve the data generation and
processing
is increasing on a daily basis and you
might be looking at
10 terabytes per day of data across labs
all the way to microscopy where you
might be looking at
hundreds of petabytes of data over time
this requires not just challenges to be
addressed in terms of standardization
and descriptor evolution but
primarily around sustainability how are
we going to sustain
that scale of data transfer and storage
are going to be equally important things
both locally and in the cloud or across
networks and how do you compute on such
data
we are already saying that computing on
some of the data sets
might need to happen very close to the
data as opposed to
pulling the data from wherever it is
through a mechanism like data lab and
computing on it locally
and finally to be able to truly extract
knowledge
we need data sets to be inter
interoperable
in the sense that they have to have
sufficient metadata
to be able to be reused for other
purposes
at this point i think the culture of
sharing has evolved quite a well
but we are still expecting a lot of
evolution in the process of sharing data
as soon as it's generated collaborating
with
others in the cloud or on data centers
and then creating a community of
practice around
the best practices that would be
required to distribute data to
compute on it and to evolve and coalesce
into well-validated workflows that might
exist
and this kind of leads me to the last
section of
of this talk uh a little bit of forward
looking as to what we might expect
and i'll go back to the work we do in
our group some of the things we are
interested in
is the ability to measure things about
an individual
to predict outcome like treatment or
behavioral trajectories
and to adjust uh how an individual might
behave
through interventions or the way they do
things and be able to re-measure and
this is kind of a cycle what we are
interested in is thinking about
trajectories across individuals
that might overlap diverge or
change to certain states that might
cause illnesses
but to be able to do this we need both
objective and
subjective measures now objective
measures are growing on a daily basis
with various kinds of wearables and
other
data sets that are coming online but
this is really about longitudinal data
about an individual
and we might we are hoping that we can
feed this
into some of our models and algorithms
that learn from the data
to provide better or more precise
indicators
to an individual or their caregivers and
this will require what
many people have said as deep
longitudinal phenotyping
in fact this figure on the right is from
about five years back
netapp a company that specializes in
storage
was already thinking about how the human
body would give
rise to a large amount of data
as time progresses and if you now think
of this as kind of longitudinal data
every single human is going to be
producing scales of data that you might
not have been thinking about previously
and this might be brain images and
signals
but it's also data from smartphones and
wearables
the genetic data especially if you now
consider transcriptomic and other types
of genetic transformations
are exploding at a rapid scale and size
clinical records are more accessible
although there's lots of
difficulties in getting to them right
now and then the word of
world of microbiomes is also changing
some of these scales of data as we speak
so how we preserve even our own
individual data is something we have to
think about
moving forward not just institutional
and structural
information that's stored in clinical
centers
and one of the projects i really
appreciate in this space is something
called
is a project called open humans which
allows
storing your own data into a personal
data store
and what this means is that you have
control over your data
you decide who to give it to you could
donate it for research you could do your
own research or you could explore
things by yourself and i think it's a
fantastic model for us to consider
as we move forward in thinking about
both privacy considerations but also
being able to aggregate
large amounts of data when we need to
solve problems
and this will still require the kind of
work that we were doing in the
neuroimaging data model but
the scale of all biomedical data we need
to be able to link
extract search over information even if
the raw underlying data may not be
accessible
we may need to compute over information
in privacy preserving ways as well
so it's something to keep in mind as we
think about the scale of data if we
could do this
maybe tomorrow well maybe not tomorrow
but maybe over a short period of time
we are able to ask questions for
specific disorders where there may not
be
large amounts of data in these public
archives we might be able to develop
algorithms and tools that actually
operate on real data and takes care
of bias across data sets and this will
require
access to data in a way and even open
humans where the model is fine
would still require evolving to the
scale and tune of data that's coming
online
and one of the projects in that space is
called the interplanetary file system
it's a way of distributing data across
nodes and networks
in a way where data is not just stored
in a central archive or a central
repository
but gets distributed to make certain
aspects of data access
and distribution much more efficient now
this may not be a solution for all
biomedical data tomorrow
but this is an architecture that one can
think about
in thinking about both private data sets
public data sets
and distributing data sets over the
planet
the final thing i'm going to end with
is the need for education
so on the left the missing semester of
your cs education is a website at mit
that teaches people about the things
that are not
often taught in courses
and these are critical in the world of
analytics and data systems
that exist today some of the things that
every student
should our researchers should know how
to be able to do is to make their com
computation portable to be able to go
from one system to another
to be able to transition from one
hardware architecture to another
there has to be a better way of doing
debugging
the iterative process that's often
involved in many of the analytic tools
especially deep learning and other
technologies requires us moving or
iterating on the problems
faster we have to be able to track
provenance if we have to show people
what a model was trained on how well it
can do
and metadata curation which is something
that's often ignored in most
analytics places needs to become
a more concerted effort and a systematic
effort across researchers and labs
we have to be able to compute
efficiently at the scales of data we are
seeing otherwise we will be waiting for
just computation to finish
bias and quality control are going to be
essential
with the rate at which data are emerging
a lot of data are being put out there
without uh
quality control and that's a good thing
in my opinion however as a community
we need to be able to label or annotate
the data sets
so that downstream users can decide
whether they want to use certain types
of data
for all of the software and analytic
tools testing and reproducibility and
validation are going to become critical
and for many domains where we don't have
ground truth available the community
kind of has to come together to
establish best practices
or principles by which we evaluate
not just from looking at the result and
whether it aligns with our hypothesis
but some more principle mechanisms
whether through
computational modeling or others to say
that what we are observing as a result
of the analytics
is actually what we want to see and
the scale of data is going to parallel
the scale of computing
which will go back to the kinds of tools
and technologies
that a student or a researcher might
need to learn today
to be able to deal with this explosion
of data that's happening
with that i'm going to thank you for
your attention and i'm
happy to take any questions sasha thank
you so much man you covered a ton of
ground that is really fantastic
um let me see couple of questions we
have one from
a one of our viewers here how do you
quantify
or mitigate uncertainty when deploying
machine learning techniques
in your data analytic quests are there
confidence intervals are those a big
deal should we be
paying attention to those uh
wonderful question so i can say about
one of the approaches we are taking
with bayesian neural networks which
as an inbuilt mechanism of that
architecture
provides us access to entropy or
uncertainty that we can leverage
so when it runs it kind of says
this is how certain i'm about what i'm
telling you
now many of these things as one might
know
could be confident about some things and
we haven't solved every problem with
uncertainty
but at least using these bayesian neural
networks
is one step of evaluating uncertainty
that we think can be useful
in the short term one thing that is
super
interesting about kind of the story you
just told is you know
kind of beginning with an effort i was
involved with
moons ago where we were delivering data
to people
on dvd and if you kind of think about
that time
uh it was about the same time that like
netflix
started to become popular and how did
you get your
movie of the week from you know from
netflix well you ordered it and they
delivered it on
on a media like a compact disc or or dvd
and so it wasn't unusual and we were
very sensitive to the fact that you know
filling up somebody's ethernet pipe with
you know streaming
neuro imaging data would very often
bring some networks to their knees
and so we actually specifically chose
that as a medium to act as kind of a
governor on the system right so that we
didn't have
one a lot of people complaining at us
that we you know
had basically having the investigators
being complained about that they'd
crash their own internets about it uh at
the same time
realizing that the the ability to stream
effectively that kind of data writ large
was going to be a real challenge
and we just the technology of the time
wasn't equipped for it
even netflix wasn't equipped now we take
that for granted right we stream stuff
to our phones
you know sitting on the on the bus or
something um
and so it that the technologies continue
to to move forward and that is certainly
something that we've seen
in neuroimaging with all the different
approaches and methodologies and
services
that that you mentioned and you know
things like this uh i hadn't heard of
the ipfs but you know you could imagine
being able to to do that
and i'm also was intrigued by the um
the net app talking about uh the
the netapp thing of 665 terabytes worth
of just
individual data that brought to mind the
quantified self
project which was uh kind of popular a
few years ago
but then linking into open humans if we
all quantified ourselves
that would be and you know made that
data distributed distributable through
ipfs and had all these quantitative
tools
it would really be quite an impressive
amount of stuff at our fingertips on
demand when we wanted it
it would be quite impressive absolutely
i i thought you might get a kick out of
that fmridc
uh slide over there jack
it was uh it was good you know it's
interesting it was it was
pioneering for its time um but uh i
just i marvel at what we started
um because there's just been so much
work done in this area which is just so
remarkable and you just summarized it
for us so
and one of the things i will say is uh
we are not
uh at the stage where everything can go
over the internet yet
so i i'm i know of a project within the
brain initiative cell census network
that sends data by tape drives
because even the internet is
insufficient to send that data over
so they're collecting fluorescence micro
optical sectioning tomography or fmos
data
which are close to a petabyte
if you collate all those tapes together
and
that becomes almost impossible to send
over the internet
today yeah it's a real challenge and
we're going to have to think very
carefully about how we
instead of moving data to where the
processing happens to
possibly take processing to where the
data live
and it has to be i think both of those
things which is why i'm excited about at
least the
future of things like ipfs and again i
think
whether that exact technology is what's
adopted i don't know the answer
but i think the concepts in that
technology are really good
and we will see this kind of
mixed movement of either data or
computation
in the future world of research
analytics and if that can indeed be
coupled
with the personal data stores like open
humans
it just simply opens up a scale and
potential
for human-oriented research
that i think would transform
almost everything we are doing around
human research today
well satra gosh from the mcgovern
institute of brain research
at mit thank you so much for sharing
your work with us and all these
exciting efforts um so thankful to have
you join us
and um we will not be having a uh
data science seminar series next friday
first because of some other activities
that we're doing for our
2020 2021
innovation lab participants but we'll be
seeing you again
soon here in the future once again thank
you satra
everyone enjoy a great weekend